music and stuff
you wanna save my soul?
tell'n you girl, I sold mine
No, no, no
to the devil
read it
you know who I am? which is a problem. A problem that has to go away
(pleading) I don't deserve to die!
everyone says that
(car vrooming, man pleading)
generally works in our department, we will get an outline
when we get our first script we then go through it and basically notate all of the areas, that very clearly screams visual effects
and then I go through it
and spend a few days where I am actually going through every scene, and I technically break down how we're gonna shoot
Jed basically called me and said hey, I mean it's a huge IP
On a show like this
and being at ten o'clock and do all the extra things up how we're gonna deal with the tone. In a little darker way but still fun
it's gonna be great
so... you've got the devil inside you too?
technically, I designed a-a hood that has LEDs on it. Powered up as a flicker and adjust I'm different color temperatures.
So, we have some of the yellow, that actually works very nicely, and so it flickers, so the jacket is lit up. It would be lit up if you were a light source.
so, then we open it up more, to get more of his face
An have tracking markers on there
and really its about trying to get, his emotions, what he sort of is expressing, through his face.
And apply that to eye orbits and all that kinda stuff
to me it was about having a character  that the audience can actually connect with.
can actually relate to and feel
and so thefeore it became about what sort of things can I add to it like a little burning coal eye
the fact that the eye orbits
the fact that the eye orbits, ya know squash and stretch for expression
the fact that this area here, essentially works like an exhaust pipe
started  using motion capture last season a little bit on season two as well. we ended up cyber scanning and we take him and make a visual representation of him
that's the character. the beautiful thing about motion capture is that if your an animator trying to just animate a digital double,
wall the nuances, the weight shifts, the little micro movement, its very hard.
to sort of make  that come through on  just typical character. So, motion capture enables you to capture all of the stuff. so anyways, yeah, sort of the process with
hey youtubers, its Charlie. so new Ghost Rider trailer where he drops the name of the devil. so very important
Let's break it down
the big thing here is called episode two is called meet the new boss
the A story is introducing the new director of shield, the Jason Omoro character. But I think like the B meaning is like we have all this Ghost Rider footage is that you're gonna learn about the new boss of the streets
as well as ghost rider's boss, like the Ghost Rider persona. Or maybe even Mephisto
Because I talked about Mephisto in my Marvel Phase 4 video yesterday.
Because the actor who plays Ghost Rider is talking about him
Mephisto appeared in the Ghost Rider movie (ew)
He's important for a number of things, Marvel Avengers stories. Including, the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
So everybody is just wondering what Mephisto's  status is
In the MCU
and even though they don't say a whole lot, Marvel actually does know each exact character that they're capable of doing in the movies
The Russo Brothers said that like when they were plotting out the Infinity War, the had boards on all the walls of this specific room with people that were alive and that were dead.
The current status of everybody from like the most minor of characters, like Galaga man, from the first Avengers film, all the way up to like Thanos and even the new
new, big A-list Characters that they have not rolled out yet, like Captain Marvel.
So we're all wondering about Mephisto. Marvel knows... but they usually like to keep quiet about stuff like this to let people speculate
Just to lure on the side of caution, like usually they could be more effective, when they don't confirm or deny things
they just let the fandom just have fun with it.
It remains to bee seen whether or not mephisto makes his presence during Agents of Shield
So the way Ghost rider talks about it, in this footage, he talks about selling his soul to the devil
That's actually a bit of a twist on comic book origin story. So one, they're either changing it just a little bit. Like, ya'know he ends up dying in a street race to try and raise money
For his brother's condition, to help support his brother who's on a wheelchair. Or he only thinks he sold his soul to the devil. And its like a twist and the person he sold it to is somebody different
So it just remains to be seen, but the whole idea of episode two is showing you the characters that were only mentioned in the first episode. So, it's like ya'know pulling the curtain back
a little bit more. so on the lighter side of things, one I'm hoping we find out the name of the new director of shield. Like is he gonna be like the Jim Hammond original Human Torch
And two, on the darker side of things
we're a little bit more about what the TV show is doing with this  version of Ghost Rider
Because just like the Marvel movies and the Netflix series change little things about comic book backstories
Like the idea with The Mandarin in Iron Man 3 (ew)
Like the real mandarin is out there somewhere. Like even though they don't  go with Mephisto on Agents of Shield, Is the origin of this Ghost Rider
Which wasn't necessarily gonna happen in the comics that doesn't mean  that Mephisto is not apart of the MCU
But it seems like everybody is really jazzed up about Ghost Rider. It's amazing how much flaming skull with
good special effects can people  around. Like before the season came out everyone was kinda fifty -fifty.
on this version of Ghost Rider like "oh you know Johnny blaze" one of my favorite ghost Riders
But we never seen Diego Luna, the actor Who's playing Ghost Rider. That's his name in real life
And he rides in Fast an furious style like "oh yeah this is awesome , it's gonna be alotta fun"
Let me know what you guy think in the comics,
that they'll be like super accurate to this Version of Ghost Rider in the comics, or you think they will roll big in trying to tease Mephisto's
Now I'm  not expecting the actual devil to make an appearance anytime soon
Introducing the Ghost Rider character.
All about his ark, about his family. why he became Ghost Rider
What is S.H.I.E.L.D gonna do about him because
he's something way beyond, way more powerful than Inhumans
They've faced so far. with maybe the exception of Hive, because the way hid power works but you know for know it seems
Like Ghost Rider mostly is going to be an antagonist
Until something works comes along which is really like the mystery spirit come in which  is it really appear in the trailer so I don't know how big
it's gonna be in an episode
But look out for the fun the have with making you think there is conflict inside
of each of these groups like Ghost Rider conflict, even though
we know he's probable gonna end up being a good character in conflict
a new director who actually seems like a
a really good person, who is just a super hard ass
But congratulations to this weeks giveaway winner, Booya.
Awesome name, I always liked names that double as expressions
You win a gift certificate for the Captain America Civil War blu-ray
Just be sure to private message me at the back end of my channel
The rumored spiderman trailer is still a couple weeks away
haven't heard any crazy news about that recently